couple 1018 little Roxy L think I was
about 16 years old he didn't stand in it
and he just had like a man trillion
dollars worth of jewelry or chicks and
now the first time I ever witnessed my
Tyson judo's just watching you last
night
sure wait stock tank I'm a big fan I
love it we have a good time
whoa Mike you want to bring us they're
gonna be uh everybody welcome to another
episode of hot box yeah hey everybody
welcome to another episode of hot box
and I'm Evan Britton and I'm Mike Tyson
Mike we got a great guest here brother
man this is a really memorable one don't
forget this one the one the only Daymond
John welcome if you beat you oh yeah I
love it now all right thanks for coming
it's an honor
I am excited have you guys known each
other for a while for years I've been
over yet yeah we we you know we have a
lot of history a lot of history that
might probably doesn't know but he might
know might not remember yeah we do well
first time obviously that
he didn't know me first time I remember
getting a couple of dollars and I went
to this went to this club and I snuck in
and that's the first time I saw the
heavyweight champion of the world club
called 10:18 old rocks Yale Club I think
I was about 16 years old he was just
standing there and he just had like a
trillion dollars worth of jewelry on for
chicks and my dude outside was a
stick-up kid and they say yo Mike Tyson
in there and they're like we sticking up
that model wheels wasn't a key but my
boy wasn't take his chain off and give
it to Mike bucket yeah there's another
one big man and that was the first time
I ever witnessed Mike Tyson I forgot
those that's epic dude growing up in New
York City that's amazing well I was just
I just read an article about you yeah
and it made it was really interesting
because it ties directly to something
we've we just talked about earlier today
which was the hip hop culture in New
York City yeah when Mike was coming up
tying Mike to the hip hop community but
then how you how FUBU was really
inspired out of that as well yeah of
course absolutely when we came up in New
York those days you know really really
have anybody to look up to you know in
84 and 85 and we did have to look up to
was this young emerging group of drug
dealers because crack had just started
to devastate the neighborhood so we had
these people in our neighborhood named
supreme and fat cat and called Lee and
all these people that we used to look up
to we wanted to be like them but on the
flip side thank God I grew up in Hollis
Queens and they say something must be in
the water cuz the same exact time hip
hop started hit Hollis Queens and
instead of just having an Envy supreme
team and all these guys we start to look
at people who talking from house Queens
Run DMC LL Cool J salt and pepper Tribe
Called Quest Lost Boys ja Rule onyx 50
Cent's and we started see all these guys
we started say wait a minute we can make
money doing something we love and I
don't have to go to jail you know and
and and and so hip hop just saw to
inspire me but I realized I couldn't rap
sing or dance I could dance actually I
started to dance that actually you know
I saw the dance tell you the truth and
then I remember going to a audition for
to for Houdini to become a dancer for
Houdini and they said okay I'll take you
on tour my mother said you ain't going
on no talk and then Jermaine Dupri's get
out of Atlanta took my position you know
to me oh wow but it's funny you I
started being able to go on these tours
in like 86 like just you know roadie and
all of my friends and I we didn't know
how to rap we all aspire to be something
in that space so one of my friends said
I'm gonna be the best movie directing my
other friend said I'm gonna be the best
music executive I said I'm gonna be in
fashion somebody got a dress all these
people and my other friends said I'm
still gonna stay a drug dealer but those
friends have been being Irv Gotti hype
Williams my other friend who said is
gonna be the best drug deal still in
jail and hype made the movie belly about
him so we all ended up hitting what we
wanted to be yeah good bad or
indifferent but it changed my life and I
was I just was I was really just making
the clothes I could so I could be the
last person that kicked off the video
set yeah because I just went to holla at
all the video girls and so when I tell
when they bout to come and kick me over
but now y'all I'm about to dress the
artist man yeah I had the same stinky
nasty shirt talkin me I'm gonna dress
the artist so they can kick me off how
old were you I was about 19 at that time
that's amazing tell us the story about
you guys getting LL Cool J to throw one
of your shirts on and that kind of
started this whole initial campaign yeah
so L lived in the neighborhood and I
think they were shooting the hail of a
video or something like that around the
neighborhood but what I did at first was
I
I used I only had a couple of shirts so
what I did at first is I used to make
only four X's and six X's because I knew
the big guys
didn't have a lot of fashion at that
time Yeah right and I knew the big guys
we're gonna wear a 6x and wear my style
every day if they could because now they
had something fly to wear and usually
they were the bodyguards yeah so I
dressed as many of them as I could and
after L saw those things for a while he
started to get used to the product and
was like you know he wasn't afraid of it
and I remember him him trying to he was
he was about to come out here to shoot
in the house and I sit outside of his
door for about five six hours and I
begged him the word and he said you know
I you know I couldn't look at my
community in the face if I didn't
support you so if you ever get anywhere
and you won't you take care of me
he took one shot when I was leak when
when he was leaving the California and I
wouldn't I thought I'd never see him
again because he moving out of the
neighborhood and we took that pitch and
we just ran with it everywhere that's
crazy that's all she wrote that's all
she wrote it's amazing and it was good
good time
no it's awesome dude Mike you know LL
you want me tell you another time I ran
into Mike Tyson let me know please
Mike was about to fight Lennox Lewis and
and so we heard best way to get in touch
with microwave all new people like a
door and a lot of people that might
might make growing up with and we was
like we got to get to Mike because he
just I don't know he just came home but
he was he was he was I know we just want
to get to get a hole-in-one would call
in Virginia : and we can never get to
Mike because we want to dress him for
the fight and they were like he also
doesn't really wear logos on the trunks
I mean he just comes in you know weight
comes in so we finally got ahold of
Lennox Louis and he is our boy and we
dressed Lennox Mike finds out we're
dressing Lennox I go to his house in
Vegas there's a big party Mike Tyson
party now my bodyguard used to work with
Mike the name is grim we're at the house
Mike comes out and there's a bunch of
people around he's having a good time
then he walks up to me and he just he
pokes me in my chest and put like a
little hole in my oh man and he said yo
what [__] would you dress Lennox Lewis
he can't even sell pantyhose I'm like yo
man but Mike we were trying to get a
hold of you who you want you would do
something he said nah nah nah I'm here
to party and he looked at me really
funny for a second and my bodyguard who
knew his crew say yo let's get out he's
like no my spot to knock you to [__] out
now wouldn't that do that he was like I
seen him smack [__] and he
knocks him the [__] out like let's get
out of here and I don't want have to
start [__] up all the people I know
in here
so I leave about a year later in Vegas
the trade show something to get on a
plane I was late I'm running because you
know whatever happened I say you know
what I got to get a red-eye I got to
head out of here I'm gonna leave my
whole staff there I get on a plane
guess who sits next to me [__]
Mike Tyson sits next to me and goes
hello I go oh it's [__] I don't
know who I am right so I just stand here
looking out the window for most of the
time and I said to myself I still I
still there's about a year to half or
two years ago I still felt that pain
from that that little poke that he gave
me and I remember the waitress bringing
over the drink the drink and sat in
between the he fell asleep and all night
I was trying to spit in his drink so let
me get a tuna fish sandwich so I can
make sure there's some substance in this
[__] drink right now we later
we getting our bags and then my
partner's on a plane and Mike didn't
really put together it was me and my
partner's together and we were leaving
any look like he looked at us like that
is my thank God I spit in your drink
babe
thank God you didn't do this man good we
think about how guardsmen greasy supreme
those guys and prince and all those guys
messed up you know me
flu it's hard man growing up there's so
many things that were taking us in the
wrong direction you know any better man
I'd never thought I'd live to be 25
anything me neither
we were all told that we had what 21 my
mother told me that nothing to me be
alive and we're here God is good driving
you know me I think that I was a little
kid I was dyslexic and my father left
the ten and I never will see him again
I'll speak to him again and you know I
kind of became the man of the house that
age and my mother uh brilliant and
hard-working woman she works unless she
could I just didn't want to see her work
that hard and I just always wanted to be
able to I felt bad if I would ask my
mother for something cuz I know she
ain't got it and when we were growing up
the same way I loved fashion you know
listen I wanted a bubble cold I wanted a
eight-ball jacket or I wanted some Bosco
jeans or something like that and I just
felt like only way to do it is by
earning it and then I just became really
good with numbers and then we used to
have this gang in it with two type of
gangs in my neighborhood called Hollis
crew and another one called boom bash
and and cuz I was a little kid I was
really small I realized that the best
way to to not get beat up and to have
these cats really just you know make
sure I was okay was to explain to them
how they should make money doing what
they do and they would always just say
leave little man alone and I started
getting known as this little man with
the little little smart man you know I
mean around the neighborhood and no
matter what any if I had a problem
they'd be like yo Lee little man alone
and I said listen I can I can make moves
doing this I think I can get places
doing this you know so and that grew and
to it was always my validation to get on
a video set or be one of the people that
they left alone or something of that
nature or because they value the brain
they were just basically say you know
little hustler and they they value that
that's pretty awesome and I was just the
other guy and they would just robbed
anybody had no Robert Robert Churchill
drop anybody you know if there's an
opportunity my mother's boyfriend
forget drunk fall asleep [__] get his
pocket just anybody but you would have
thought that the dude who helped you
figure out how to handle money would
have probably been pretty valuable yeah
extremely valuable yeah yeah for sure
because these are the things that you
never learn in school
no even going to college now you know
unless you're majoring in finance or
something like that yeah but if you're
majoring in finance they'll teach you
they'll teach you how the numbers work
but then they won't teach you how to
sell all right so you'll get one aspect
of it which is which is extremely
valuable but then how do you find your
customer how do you sell how do you
produce a good you know what I mean like
how do you couple all those things
together to make it you know to make it
work yeah bombas man I think it's
awesome
homeless people that's the most
requested item acai yeah well tell them
they came on the show they were doing
about 800,000 I think a year nothing
they're gonna do about a hundred million
a year but more importantly they learn
me a very valuable lesson you know years
ago when we used to just give at the end
of the year you know at the office give
to charitable organizations but like you
just said the homeless have a special
need and every time these the the bombas
people sell a pair of socks they give a
pair away to the homeless and what I
learned is today's customer today's
consumer they want to know that they
every time they spend a dollar that
they've contributed toward the
betterment of something else some other
cause or what are the cases and they
don't give at the end of the year no
more they basically say then the yeah
I've given to 500 different
organizations and because today
everybody you know you open up your
phone everybody sells everything so now
it's even more important to know that
there's a back story behind it and the
people aren't just trying to make a
profit nothing wrong with that but the
people are also helping you other people
on the way and it really has changed a
lot of the ways that I do business and I
look at business you know when I when
FUBU was really big we never advertise
that we gave to people that needed it
because we didn't want a profit off of
people's
you know emotions and challenges but now
you almost have to tell people what
you're doing or they won't value you
there's a lot of people listening to
this minute they're there they have a
product or a service or whatever make
sure people know the story you know on
how you're going to make sure the other
people benefit off the purchase yeah
absolutely
what do you think about Tyson wrench
it's got a hell of a story I think it's
great I think it's an amazing story I
was in there looking at all looking on
all the things that are gonna happen
yeah I love the fact that there is a
decide there's a family side to it as
well you know I love the live
entertainment you know so it looks like
you know you you're making sure there's
a full spectrum of services because a
lot of people want to probably touch the
Tyson brand and have a great experience
but they don't they can't necessarily
touch it this way but they'll be able to
touch it this way yeah and also on Tyson
ranch is also associated when I was
standing in line today which is also a
group that helps some addiction and
homelessness that's right
case a point yeah well and also you know
cannabis as medicine mm-hmm for athletes
who endure you know lots of injuries and
concussions and all of that stuff yeah I
used I use CBD and I've been you know
I'm messing around a little bit because
I had a thyroid cancer two years ago
yeah so yeah did you utilize some CBD
and yeah so tell me um ever during that
moment you'd ever have doubt that you
mean that come out cool you know I I
didn't know I had the cancer until the
surgery and then when I was taking just
a lump off my thyroid then they told me
that the one and a half sir the one I
was surgery became three and a half
hours of taking out this this this thing
but it was concerning because I thank
God the thyroid cancer is the slowest
growing cancer but it was already in my
body for about three years and it was
moving up to my lymph nodes and I
wouldn't know about it unless I was
smart enough to go get an executive
physical and check on myself ahead of
time and I'm cancer-free so so so I'm
good but
it was a very scary time because you
know listen you know the it's just
something you just don't know how it's
gonna affect you you know
thank god you're it's even better now
cuz they're good yeah and it made me
start going and getting those yearly
physicals those executive physicals and
checking up on myself because a lot of
us neglected ourselves for so for so
many years you know yeah you talk a lot
about that taking good care that's not
what we do in the black family you know
guys we getting honey yeah okay we don't
have riving yeah don't think about yeah
you don't think about the money we have
surviving we get our clothes we won't
respect it look up to it in the
community yeah we so we won't get close
to get a job you know what I mean by a
suit to make sure we look clean we
didn't we wouldn't thinking about taking
care of ourselves because like Mike said
Wayne even abhi around after 21 so why
should we be worried about it because it
ain't gonna be cancer that kills us as
far as we're told no way you know but
you know Mike and I here to show that
that's not the case
no not the case no doubt Mike so how did
you decide that
Damon was cool in your eyes after the
Lennox listen I don't know these guys
look at themselves mean these guys were
part of our community man what they were
doing was man it was a what can I say it
was a form of like giving us something
we had something that was us it was from
us by us you know I mean and that's in
their nose and those words are they
rippled across the nation and across the
world and everybody supported him that's
why they became who they were
everybody always respected them you know
me I'm sure there's always people that
had hating them up late but I bet you
they wore the product it's just what it
is you know me when you even when the
idea is come and his time has come
nothing can stop it and that's how FUBU
would let one a time it came nothing
could stop though
he is rolling down all the competition
do you feel that way you know I was so
closer I was just doing what we loved I
was just um I was just trying to make
sure everybody got you know got to be
able to touch the brand and understand
that we just loved hip-hop yeah these
guys are out in the community they
weren't hiding they were high
a mansion and they within the community
people who see them people could touch
them they were at the club there at the
celebrity basketball thing they were
there you can touch them it is just a
good feeling you know to feel like you
belong and not having to watch you watch
your back and then then starting to see
actually people say you know what I was
always always wanting to be an
entrepreneur and because of you guys you
made me feel like I could be one and and
then I'm also loving the fact that
listen other cultures had valued the
brand as well and you know we weren't
bigots we would love to say that listen
this is powered by an african-american
culture called hip-hop but if you love
hip-hop we'll rock with you
you know you know people that always ask
me were you only going to just dress
people of color no listen if Eminem
wanted to he wanted baddest rappers on
the planet if third base wanted
something no problem I don't I don't I
didn't care who it was as long as they
loved hip-hop
it's a FUBU jeans why men there you go
it's love I did not love anybody I mean
I was thinking that reading this article
today about like you were talking about
Mike it's as if you know this thing had
to come into existence you know if this
this company this this idea that you had
and it's amazing that you know you were
put here on the universe to bring this
into the african-american community you
know you know I will have to give credit
to have you ever heard have you ever
heard of Reggie Lewis yeah from meet
beaches no from beaches yeah Reginald
Lewis but you know I I got inspired by
Karl Kani and I got inspired by cross
color so you know I got to give it up to
those who inspired me as well yeah and
so I think maybe with it they would they
were born to do that and then then I
then I I piled it up their footsteps a
little bit yeah well I think it's all in
the channel was off the hook all was
great yeah it's all in the chain of
energy of how things get created and
brought into the world man so it's
awesome
my ask you and I think it's cool that
you've transitioned it into a new
company really get into a licensing
company yeah I think that's really cool
I think
you never hear that about businesses
right now and so I think if you could
talk a little bit about that I think
that's really interesting yeah I don't
do that
well when fool you know most fashion
brands hot brands you know they stay hot
for you five to seven years right and
then they kind of go off and they return
every 10 or maybe 20 years now when I
talk about you know like Louis Vuitton
or Nike that have this consistency you
got the the unicorns of the world or
recently over the last two three years
you know FUBU has had this resurgence
now we always have license because you
know to expand globally you can't just
do it yourself your license something
into Korea your license something in
other territories you license different
categories so like we won't make boots
let's have somebody else make boots
somebody else make fragrance and the
recently you know I you know the the the
the kids and people out they have just
been requesting food I guess because
maybe the things that happened with
Gucci and Prada or all these other
things where people were started say you
know why don't we got Ford and Kevin get
that but that Dan absolutely oh yeah
yeah he's being honored at the Met the
Met Gala this year so off the hook he's
the greatest and and and yeah so we
started turning into a license coming to
license out the name to people we think
are going to add value to it and expand
the brand and that's what we've been
doing and people have been calling us
now for food with documentaries and
movies scripted shows about the crazy
days of FUBU with you know sexist drugs
rock and roll fashion you know I mean
and all the crazy stuff so so it's
really good we turned it into a great
licensing company that's awesome man
well it's really it sort of has its own
identity it's like a cultural icon
FUBU I would say it's the first hash tag
right or yeah yeah well one of the words
hash tags for clothing that's great
first hash tag well what else you got
going on man you've got it you're gonna
be interviewing Mike I'm gonna be
interviewing Mike I got I got a new hole
coming out yeah it's about to book yeah
the folks call power shift right it's
going to be you know talking about the
art of the three processes of how you
progress whether in business or in life
where you know you nurture relationship
then you negotiate relationship
and then you and then you make sure how
do you program that mind do that wobbly
be asking you because I mean think about
like this I mean I'm gonna be I want to
know how did Mike out of my you know
negotiate the or get ready an influence
and curtain the credibility of before
walking in the ring how many of his
opponents that he mentally beat before I
was stepping into the ring and then
gotta be just so first yeah you know
yeah biggest challenge in life is
ourselves gotta figure out add-ons
yourself yeah you know life is the trip
you know we think our life is only
physical yeah we think with most people
I'm not thinking I'm not saying
everybody cuz we believe he wants me
dead it's over that's that's that's
that's what I want to get to you you
know you don't you know listeners you
know it's no easy feat to be the the
baddest man on the entire planet yeah
right so you know when in so when people
think about it I want it I want to know
what mentally you have to go to you know
I mean to be the baddest man on the on
the in the whole world yeah you know
some mentality it's gotta be because it
starts there right can't be physical
right we just think it first
oh yeah we are who you are right now
what we think we are we are we are right
now we're not even real we're who we
thought we thought I felt up we some in
that self because of thoughts trip well
right now I'm a blunt in this room and I
think I am right now I'm a blunt
David you're in for a ride I can't feel
my toes and you've got an album an
elevational oh no I'm gonna play myself
that's right that's right so I yes right
I got you know a lot of times when we
hear you know my speeches you know you
know once you hear once you really
needed hear it again but if you can
score it and I remember on our street it
was one of the days when I was it was
Martin Luther King's birthday and you
know it's that's this hands down to me
one of the greatest speeches ever
and somebody was DJ was playing and he
was just putting some music behind I was
like man I want to go to the gym to
workout with this speech you know me
yeah that's though so my friend was like
listen why don't I just put some you
know music something to you to your
joints so when somebody is you know on
the subway or in a car or run a
treadmill they can just listen to it
empower them so they said because all
the stuff I hear right now is [__] is
suck a dick I don't want to work after
that I want to work out to something
that's about me yeah like yo you can do
it you know that so so we putting that
out and we got a bunch of tracks out now
and we're doing that and then I'm about
to start shooting the 11th year of shark
tank
so shark tank 11 11 years of seeing
these amazing entrepreneurs come on
there and 11 years of fighting would mr.
wonderful I having a good time so you
know it's been a blessing you know
listen I'm 50 years old and listen I've
been an adult right since 20 that one
third of my life I'd have been on ABC
you know doling out money and having a
good time it's awesome
I used to watch yeah Fonzie
yeah the network the network that Fonzie
was on that's crazy so I'm the new black
Fonzie good for you man we love you all
right you're one of a kind
I was asking Mike who we have on we were
talking to Tony touch-tone DJ yeah
uh-huh and we were talking about how so
many superstar talents came out of New
York when you guys were coming in yeah
look new you haven't taken about news
this is what I've um my whole concept I
was born in New York myself if New York
people they know they see some itis from
their neighborhood from their culture my
next to saying great [__] I could do
that too yeah I don't get somebody else
from another coaching I'm there while
he's supposed to have that maybe that's
not for me I'm not but for my day he
knows this thing or I could do that [__]
inspires everybody in the neighborhood
yeah it's true sure yeah New York is the
ultimate hustlers ya know like in a
small town people in a small town if
there's a superstar everyone's like oh
they were special mm-hmm but in New York
is you're just right in there yeah like
I wanna do that I want to be right do
that no problem yeah yeah yeah
absolutely it's also you got so much
determination but they still know what
to do it but now I gotta go this guy
gave me a goal yeah even if it's being
the best gangsta nor what the best
basketball whatever it is what other
direction is that my hunger and
determination my will exceed succeed
that's gonna get me there it'll Harden
you're growing up there because you know
you gotta go through 15 obstacles just
to get to the store and get back right
and they may not be children Obie
gametophyte in front of you and then all
of a sudden yeah then the cops come and
we all got a run because everywhere
arrested I'm just trying to get some
bread they made you commit should here
then you gotta get on the train to go if
you give you going to the city and you
gotta get on there what a thousand
people there's a bump in on crazy you
know and right runner you let your board
meeting my stop
so go well you know listen New York you
know true you feel you out you will
catch a [__] fifty in the face quick
they don't lie to got line it you know I
know a lot of people here here Mike and
I took when I say a buck fifty you know
that the raids that means a razor blades
cut her across the face where you'll
have a hundred and fifty stitches for
those who you don't know but you mess
with they'll hook you just like that I
cut those pretty faces there that's why
I decide to sell hats and yeah that's
saying who were some of your
inspirations growing up like some of the
guys you look up to in business um I
looked up to well business well maybe it
was maybe it was a drug dealer but I
don't know no I definitely looked up to
as we were just talking my supreme but I
looked up to Russell Simmons I really
loved you know all the stuff that uh you
know I loved Muhammad Ali obviously for
seeing his brand grow the way he was how
amazing he was well we didn't have a lot
you know you know we didn't really have
a lot to look up to what we saw that we
were looking at somebody like our color
you know we have Reggie Lewis but in the
way with hip - yeah yeah and and also
the Johnson the people on that Johnson
published in - yeah but they weren't
ready Lewis the first big we know we
didn't know about like social very hard
and nobody's writing them up and the
only time you saw somebody even on TV
with money if they weren't you know a
basketball player III all just looked at
this entrepreneur on TV but didn't look
like he was doing that well it didn't
look like Fred G Sanford the junkman
yeah was doing that well as an
entrepreneur so we didn't have many many
people to look up to I'm depressed what
did Reggie Lewis - Mike knows the full
story already yeah ready - um he's a
young guy
I forgot back in the day and he started
this company called Beatrice
looking look him up come on man fact
Beatrice ya rijalullah Beatrice foods
hey so man you're not depressing me I'm
just like oh yeah yeah okay Beatrice
Reggie yeah Reginald Lewis yes oh yeah
like B is very similar food service
company I believe it was like a version
of Goya so they made Beatrice C II at
the end I'm Dyslexic Reginald Lewis
talk about Lena talked about he was one
of the richest african-american men in
the 1980s and the first african-american
to build a billion-dollar
TLC Beatrice International Holdings in
1993 Forbes listed Lewis among the 400
richest Americans with a net worth
estimated at 400 million recruited to
top New York law firm paul weiss rifkind
wharton & garrison LLP immediately after
law school Lewis left to start his own
firm two years later after 15 years as a
corporate lawyer with his own practice
he moved to the other side of the table
by creating TLC Group LP a venture
capital firm in 1983 yeah you know what
I looked up to I looked up to this guy
and Ralph McDaniels who had him yeah you
do music box my man yeah before BT and
before vh1 and I also looked at this
great DJ everybody used to love named
Frankie Crocker
I know Frankie dead now he was he was
sorry to see Frankie that raise you
round McDaniel video music vine yeah
Frankie everybody like most of the big
artists Jay Paul all them they all beg
at one time another for Ralph to either
played a video or put them on a show
Ralph ah he still boots on the ground
still amazing guy who just really cares
about the community off the host
beautiful person yeah great playful
person but end of the day you know I
think all of us at the table have been
around the world and I think I can try
to complain all I want but I've seen I
see some [__] yeah so my getting robbed
the commercial where the store but I've
seen people I've seen places where
people are drinking out of the same
water the animals of [__] all right so
it and you know what I I'm not here to
complain yeah yeah no exactly
I'm here I'm here to be you know
positive and say that no matter who you
are whether you're you know any one of
us at the table you can make it you
absolutely bound to make it no doubt
about it
really bad places out there yeah yeah
you know people have no rightfully human
rights
no human right they're still in slavery
you know yeah yeah it's crazy dude well
[__] man it's been a pleasure having
Thank You Man I had my I've been I've
been one to tell Mike to spit in your
drink
story for about oh that's an amazing
story I want to get that off my chest
and a safe from environment yeah yeah
you overcome your sin young man thank
you
I like some of that devil's lettuce oh
thank you hey everybody thanks for
checking this episode out of hotbox and
I'm with hot not Mike Tyson knows how to
tell anybody know anything about you
Damon
yeah catch me up on Instagram I'm the
shark Damon like Raymond with addy
I'll catch me on them I'm shark tank and
and all that good stuff and check out my
motivational tracks you know get
yourself excited oh yeah I'm gonna yeah
no doubt
subscribe to our YouTube channel
everybody hotbox and with Mike Tyson
until next time we're out of here in the
house
[Music]